mes chers amis je dois vous avouer que
c'est avec une certaine émotion que je
m'exprime devant vous aujourd'hui
après 20 mois de silence et c'est vrai
que vous retrouvez aujourd'hui mauvais
pour moi une dimension particulière bien
sûr dans un instant je vais évidemment
évoqué les questions politiques comme
l'ont fait mes amis avant moi mais
peut-être juste avant sur un plan
peut-être plus personnel et plus
affectif vous dire que j'ai quelques
temps à traverser une période assez
violente et que même si c'est pas
comparable d'aucune manière à ce que
pourrait être une grave maladie ou la
perte de quelqu'un qu'on aime c'est vrai
que j'ai eu besoin d'entamer une période
de silence de réflexion d'ecoute de
partage aussi de résilience comme on dit
c'était lié à cette triste affaire dite
bygmalion vous le savez qui m'avait
conduit à quitter mes responsabilités de
président de l'ump et en même temps
c'est vrai que les 20 mois que j'ai eu
l'occasion de vivre avec je dois dire
beaucoup d'entre vous ont été des mois
un passionnant en fait indispensable
quand on veut se reconstruire et c'est
vrai que jamais j'aurais pu le faire si
je n'avais pas eu la chance d'avoir le
soutien de beaucoup d'entre vous et
c'est vrai que des mots comme
la solidité la fidélité l'affection la
liberté aussi la liberté de dire les
choses sans craindre de se le voir
reprocher ce ne sont pas des mots en
l'air et c'est lié aussi à cette idée
que je me fais de notre famille
politique d'être toujours en situation
d'être là quand les temps sont
difficiles de ne jamais lâcher ceux
auxquels on croit quand il se bat quand
il s'engage quand il faut les investir
dans des élections
moi je n'ai pas oublié les moments
partagés avec tous et toutes
quel que soit d'ailleurs les
sensibilités des uns ou des autres et
notamment de cette fantastique vague
bleue des municipales ou tant d'entre
vous ont été élues remportant ainsi un
succès dont nous étions si fiers les uns
et les autres
je n'ai pas oublié parce que je sais le
chemin que chacun et chacune parcours
aujourd'hui sur cette base comme de la
même manière je n'oublie pas le travail
que vous accomplissez les uns et les
autres au quotidien et que nous faisons
tous autour de nicolas notre président
alors c'est vrai que lorsque lundi
dernier les magistrats
après de nombreux mois d'investigations
m'ont fait connaître qu'ils ne me mettez
pas en examen je ne faisait pas l'objet
de poursuites
moi qui n'ai cessé de dire mon innocence
j'ai ressenti beaucoup d'émotion et
aussi je dois vous le dire un sentiment
de justice
pour tout cela je veux simplement vous
dire merci parce que vous avez été là
j'ai traversé c'est vrai comme vous tous
d'ailleurs la france une nouvelle fois
et ses vingt mois de rencontres avec les
français que j'ai consigné dans un livre
le sursaut français c'est une sorte de
réponse à tous ceux qui se lamentent et
qui font surtout commerce de déclinisme
sur le thème la france se meurt la
france est morte
pour paraphraser bossuet cette formule
terrible cette idée comme disait le
vieux maréchal que le coeur serré on
devrait cesser le combat est une idée
insupportable
même si tout est organisé pour casser le
moral de nos compatriotes parce que ça
ne correspond pas en fait à ce que pense
et à ce que disent les français eux
mêmes
j'ai vu comme vous en vérité un pays qui
va à la fois très mal mais aussi très
bien et je rêve que nous soyons plus
nombreux à le rappeler un pays dont les
habitants en ont marre d'être en
permanence
pointé du doigt pour ce qu'ils font ou
pour ce qu'ils sont alors même qu'ils
rêvent de renouer avec le succès avec la
réussite avec le positif un pays qui
veut retrouver sa souveraineté qui veut
maîtriser son destin et moi je pense que
vouloir retrouver sa souveraineté ça
veut pas dire être anti européen bien au
contraire je pense tout simplement que
ça veut dire retrouver son rang à
travers les réformes nécessaires
alors c'est vrai peut-être inspiré de
mon petit exemple j'ai eu l'impression
qu'il y avait 60 millions de pointé du
doigt en france de gens qui en réalité
qu'ils soient riches ou pauvres quelle
que soit leur origine géographique
philosophie religieuse politique en
réalité se sentent épiés contrôler et
empêcher de fait et en vérité ce qui m'a
le plus frappé en les écoutant
c'est de l'entendre en fait faire un
terrible reproche aux responsables
politiques de gauche surtout mais
parfois aussi de notre famille politique
lorsqu'ils nous disent vous n'avez pas
assez de résultats
regardez la grande bretagne l'allemagne
vous devez vous engager sur des
résultats le chômage l'insécurité
l'immigration les déficits la croissance
la vérité on l'entend si souvent c'est
lorsqu'ils nous disent pourquoi est-ce
qu'on recule à chaque fois que c'est
difficile à chaque fois qu'il ya une
contestation où une grève
ces messages là mes chers amis je pense
qu'il faut qu'on les reçoive comme ils
viennent avec d'autant plus de
considération que les mois qui viennent
vont être des mois extrêmement important
regardez encore la tragi-comédie sur le
sujet de la déchéance de nationalité
les attentats tragiques du bataclan
c'était le 13 9 ans nous sommes à la mi
février encore en train de nous entre
déchirer à cause des palinodies
gouvernementale pour une mesure qui en
réalité relève du bon sens parce que la
déchéance de nationalité on le sait bien
ne permet pas de lutter contre le
terrorisme mais elle est et c'est pour
ça que je les soutenu une manière
d'accompagner le travail de deuil des
français et bien sûr qu'il fallait cher
nicolas la voter parce que c'était une
manière évidemment de montrer que dans
ce domaine nous entendons la tristesse
et la colère de nos compatriotes
de la même manière comment comprendre
que sur un sujet comme notre dame des
landes
le président de la république alors que
c'est un dossier qui est ouvert depuis
des années 60 recul une nouvelle fois en
nous parlant d'un référendum
d'initiative locale
comment comprendre de tels d'hésitation
à un moment où ce que les français
attendent de nous c'est que l'on décide
alors c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai
que dans ce contexte l'année 2016 va
être une année extrêmement importante
pour nous parce que l'année 2010 est
sera l'année de l'élection
présidentielle est sans doute d'une
dernière chance si on veut enrayer le
déclin
vous savez il y a quelques années de
cela je parlais de la droite décomplexée
cela avait créé à l'époque quelques
débats cette idée selon laquelle la main
ne doit pas trembler quand il faut
prendre des décisions difficiles
cette idée
selon laquelle on doit nommer les choses
plutôt que de tourner autour du pot
quitte parfois avoir des polémiques
comme lorsqu avec beaucoup de mes amis
parlementaires et ils s'en souviennent
j'ai mené le débat pour convaincre les
uns et les autres qu'il fallait
interdire le port de la burqa dans notre
pays devant parfois le scepticisme ou le
sarcasme de la même manière mes chers
amis que la droite décomplexée
cela veut dire porter des valeurs parce
que je n'ai jamais compris pourquoi l'on
pouvait être fier d'être de gauche
et c'est éminemment respectable et
pourquoi il fallait sans s'excuser
d'être fier d'être de droite
alors alors fait vrai pour cela il n'y a
pas 36 solutions
je pense que nous devons dans cette
année 2016
profitez de cette opportunité unique
pour porter le débat avec les français
mais pas dans n'importe quelle condition
je souhaite pour ce qui me concerne
qu'on entende toujours cette idée vous
devez avoir des résultats
être sans doute moins plus ambitieux
dans l'obtention des résultats est plus
humble dans l'effet d'annoncé de mesures
dont on sait pertinemment qu'elles ne
résoudront pas les problèmes
alors c'est un nouvel état d'esprit avec
des mots nouveaux
celui par exemple on a tellement de mal
à prononcer la bienveillance la
bienveillance et pas la naïveté un la
bienveillance et simplement cette idée
qui consiste à chercher de ce qu'il ya
de positif chez les autres de ne pas
rejeter sur leur dos nos propres
problèmes d'essayer d'imaginer de faire
gagner les autres au service du
collectif
et puis le nouvel état d'esprit c'est le
pragmatisme c'est de vivre dans ce 21e
siècle et de comprendre qu'il n'ya plus
aucune réponse idéologie du 19e et du
20e pour répondre à l'explosion du
numérique et aux grands bouleversements
du monde d'aujourd'hui
dans ce contexte
il faudra donc une nouvelle méthode et
c'est sur ce point que je ne cesse
depuis des années de militer si nous
voulons vraiment avoir des résultats il
faut arrêter de passer autant de temps à
débattre de textes législatifs qui dure
qui dure qui dure pour régler parfois
des problèmes qui ont émergé le matin et
dont on a fait semblant d'annoncer la
solution le soir je préconise ce qui
pour moi est la seule manière de faire
ce que phil général de gaulle en 1958 le
gouvernement par ordonnance de telle
manière que le candidat qui soit issu
des primaires élabore et propose aux
français durant la campagne un contrat
avec les dix quinze propositions qui
vont enfin déverrouiller notre pays que
ces proposition soit adoptée
les premiers jours de juillet 2010 est
de telle manière qu à partir du mois de
septembre la france puisse se consacrer
à l'application des décisions et non pas
à des débats infinis pour savoir si on
doit ou non mettre en oeuvre des
décisions pour lesquelles on a été élu
ce changement mes chers amis est un
changement majeur
c'est quelque chose que nous n'avons
jamais en fait vraiment essayé que la
première année d'un quinquennat soit
consacrée à prendre les grandes
décisions et les quatre autres à les
appliquer alors on pourra aller à la fin
du quinquennat avec un résultat et une
évaluation
c'est un changement complet dans la
méthode de gouvernement
et j'y ajoute bien sûr que cela veut
dire restreindre le périmètre de l'état
tu as raison luc totalement raison
l'état ne peut pas continuer de
s'occuper tout n'importe quand n'importe
comment au gré des circonstances
ce qui compte ce n'est pas le prochain
sondage où le prochain journal de 20h
aussi intéressant soit il ce qui compte
c'est de sortir de l'immédiateté pour
s'intéresser au long terme qui seule
permet d'imprimer sa marque dans
l'histoire d'un grand pays
alors oui
je pense que ce sont trois objectifs et
trois seuls sur lesquels nous devons
travailler
le premier c'est de remettre de la
liberté économique à tous les étages et
de le faire vraiment référendum
d'entreprise généralisée numéro
d'inscription au registre du commerce
pour chaque jeune qui à l'âge de 16 ans
reçoit son numéro de sécurité sociale
pour se protéger et qui en même temps se
trouve inciter à nous et le plus vite
possible un premier contact avec le
monde du travail baisse des impôts
courageuse chiffrées sur la base de
baisse de dépenses courageuse et chiffré
réduction du déficit budgétaire mais
aussi avoir le courage de dire que si on
veut une fonction publique moderne
il faudra assumer d'en finir avec
l'emploi à vie pour les fonctionnaires
nouvellement recrutés ne pas avoir ce
courage c'est de ne pas dire la vérité
aux français
le deuxième pilier mes chers amis nous
en parlons tous il faudra l'assumer
c'est de rétablir l'ordre dans notre
pays notre pays
qu'on le veuille ou non n'est pas
aujourd'hui organisés pour lutter contre
les menaces d'insécurité depuis le
terrorisme le plus grave
jusqu aux questions de délinquance il
faudra je le préconise depuis bien
longtemps
des embauches massives dans la police la
gendarmerie la magistrature
le personnel pénitentiaire si nous ne
réussissons pas des crédits publics dans
ce domaine nous n'y arriverons jamais
arrêtons de nous mentir sur ces
questions aujourd'hui l'état n'est pas
armé outillés pour pouvoir faire face
aux menaces de délinquance et de laxisme
qui envahissent notre pays
enfin enfin le troisième pilier c'est
celui du progrès ou pour être plus
précis de réduire les inégalités des
français au service du progrès le
numérique qui est un sujet absolument
majeur face à un monde en plein
bouleversement qui fait que notre
rapport au travail et modifier regarder
humeur notre rapport à la santé et
modifier des chercheurs travaillent
aujourd'hui pour imaginer que l'on
puisse vivre demain jusqu'à 130 150 ans
imaginez la tête du débat sur la
retraite à 60 ans dans ce contexte
et puis la même manière réduire les
inégalités sur la question de
l'éducation luc chatel a raison c'est un
domaine dans lequel il faudra mettre les
pieds dans le plat sur la question de
l'autonomie totale pour nos collèges et
la question de l'apprentissage
et puis enfin les inégalités en ce qui
concerne les générations
il est des fléaux aujourd'hui dont nous
n'avons pas le courage de parler
suffisamment je pense en particulier à
la maladie d'alzheimer qui touche
d'innombrables familles et pour lequel
et pour lesquelles je regrette que notre
famille politique ne puisse pas sans
doute prendre une initiative plus
importante
je me risque pourquoi ne pas imaginer
comme nous l'avions eu le courage de le
faire il ya quelques années de renoncer
un jour férié peut-être celui du 8 mai
il ya tellement de jour férié au mois de
mai pour le consacrer exclusivement à la
lutte contre la maladie d'alzheimer qui
touche tant de familles françaises
cela m'est cher ami fait partie de cette
idée de ses idées simples que je veux qu
ensemble nous travaillons pour le bien
des français je vous disais tout à
l'heure combien j'ai milité pour une
droite décomplexée et pour finir
aujourd'hui je voudrais dire que ce dont
je rêve
en fait c'est d'une france décomplexé
parce que notre pays recèle en son sein
deux fantastiques potentialités à une
condition c'est qu'elle soit en
situation demain de se débarrasser de
ses complexes pour donner le meilleur
d'elle-même d'en avoir assez de se
regarder en baissant la tête mais plutôt
en étant fiers de nos talents parce
qu'on aura remis de la liberté
économique parce qu'on aura remis de
l'ordre et parce qu'on aura à veiller à
réduire les inégalités face au progrès
voilà mes chers amis quelques pistes de
réflexion qui me paraissent majeur pour
les temps qui viennent qui seront si
important pour l'avenir de nos enfants
car c'est bien cela le dernier mot
auquel je songe
si nous faisons tout cela c'est pas pour
nous c'est pas pour essayer ici ou là de
grappiller quelques suffrages
supplémentaires
c'est parce que si notre famille
politique qui depuis toujours incarne la
réforme le courage politique n'a pas à
coeur de veiller à ce que demain nos
enfants grâce aux décisions comprendra
auront un pays en bon état alors nos
enfants auront honte de nous et cela
n'aura plus aucun sens de s'engager en
politique pour la france
voilà pourquoi mes chers amis je crois
que le temps est important et que le
courage dont nous serons faire preuve
dans les mois qui viennent fera
évidemment la différence face aux
socialistes
comme face aux populistes et puis ne
l'oublions jamais c'est un petit secret
que je vous conte si en vérité à la fin
ce sont toujours les gentils qui gagne
merci